j'ai été accusé de meurtre quand j'étais
une jeune fille je suis détenu à
l'établissement pénitentiaire de
kingston depuis quinze longues années
s'il ya eu un crime ils veulent savoir
qu'il a commis ces gens ont besoin d'un
coupable
ça n'a pas d'importance alors vous
n'avez plus d'espoir d'être libéré je
préfère garder mes espoirs pour de
petits problèmes comme à voir demain un
meilleur petit déjeuner que celui
d'aujourd'hui
je suis le genre de médecins qui ne
travaille pas avec le corps mais avec
l'esprit la question de savoir si vous
êtes coupable ou innocente mais pas de
mon ressort
mon seul et unique objectif c'est que je
vais recouvrir la mémoire j'ai
totalement occulté cette partie de ma
mémoire
j'espère tôt ou tard me raviveront votre
je ne suis pas certaine de pouvoir la
retrouver
quand je ferme les yeux je peux me
souvenir de chaque détail de cette
maison qu'il accomplirait toujours les
mêmes tâches
du matin au soir et une maîtresse de
maison me donnerai toujours désordre tu
vas réculé seuls les temps
c'est étrange de se dire que de toutes
les personnes qui vivaient dans cette
maison j'étais la seule qui sera encore
en vie sinon plus tard avez vous vos
propres théories concernant sa santé
mentale
elle pourrait être vraiment amnésique
ou peut-être est-elle simplement
coupable s'est entouré de nombreux
dangers dans cette maison
presti d'avoir entendu son ami du
parfait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
moi au twin
les gens pensaient que vous pourriez
trouver des réponses
brûlé d'envié de me connaître docteur
[Musique]
de connaître les détails scabreux
pour me connaître par l'objet d'une
descente aux enfers
souhaitez vous rendre là où je ne peux
jamais allé
comment je peux être une meurtrière
[Musique]